these ukrainians have just escaped the
horrors of their home
arriving here to poland to submit their
paperwork and book their ticket for a
new life where are you going now we are
going
to canada the group of around 170
ukrainians is catching a flight to
moncton arranged by the new brunswick
government with help from a canadian
veterans group we see a lot of people
small children
and some elderly as well so vulnerable
populations that need our help this
family fled the fighting near harkeev
their hometown now controlled by russian
forces
there was so much bombing she says i
huddled with my son on the floor for 30
hours
i'm happy i
[Music]
really i'm happy emotionally they're
torn between excitement for what lies
ahead
and heartbreak for those left behind
part of my heart will always be here
olenna koroniska is moving to canada
without her 19 year old son it's his
choice i can't change it
her husband was killed fighting in
eastern ukraine she now wants to bring
her youngest 15 year old son to canada
how do you feel about a new a whole new
start in
canada
i'm not excited about new starts
i was afraid of bombs over my head
it seems more scared when you
can feel it when you know how it smells
burnt people important land i don't want
my child live like that dimitro blinoff
is also moving for his children
but was forced to leave his parents
behind i don't know where we can
come back to to see them again many
countries are accepting ukrainian
refugees but blenoff cited canada's
natural beauty it's large ukrainian
diaspora and most importantly it's far
away from russia it's really safe
country like
for
for a family these ukrainians will
receive a visa allowing them to work or
study in canada for three years which
could potentially be extended depending
on the size of the family they'll also
receive a few thousand dollars to get
started and after that they'll likely
need to rely on support from their new
canadian community and the community of
moncton appears ready to respond
the flight touched down to enthusiastic
applause
and the ukrainian passengers stepped off
the plane and on to canadian soil
welcome to canada thank you
how does it feel
it's actually feel great
almost unbelievable
now we are here they were met at the
airport by an army of volunteers
and in some cases an emotional embrace
[Applause]
there are so many citizens who have just
stepped up there's a free store in every
major city people have given massive
donations they'll now receive help
finding work a place to live and if
needed counseling services
the end of a long and dangerous journey
and a chance for a fresh start jeff
semple global news moncton new brunswick